[Music]
how was deputy chief Rollins is Memorial
Service Condoleezza Rice's eulogy was
surprisingly raunchy
she can write a limerick hmm Zehra
buffet you know people kept asking me
why you weren't there well my policy is
to never attend to function where I've
done LSD with more than 20 people there
MKULTRA was a weird time they seemed
suspicious suspicious dear old Henry top
oh why everyone said you hated Rollins
and then he turns up dead
good grief winters are you the only one
who thinks I didn't kill Rollins I did
not kill Rollins the North Koreans did
how do you know I pulled the ballistics
he was shot with the world's cheapest
bullet basically pop-rock stuffed inside
a lipstick tube definitely North Korea
this is scarier than being a sysadmin at
Bed Bath and Beyond
don't worry we're gonna stop these
bastards and their stacks not virus even
if it means violating civil liberties
that haven't been invented yet which it
will okay let's do this
fire it up ready to go I had the
telecoms pull every email that has ever
mentioned virus glorious leader or North
Korea I've already analyzed 11 of them
nothing only 36 trillion to go it's
probably gonna be a late night all I've
got is an encrypted telegram out of
Pyongyang a telegram how artisinal of
them what does it say Astacio pile neck
washcloth parade tricky haul I think Kim
jong-un is taking a beat poetry class or
something
that's no poem that's a directive stacks
that will go live on September 4th
you're high
no you disappoint me miss winters I
shall begin my exegesis pistachio pile
means specs met obviously Oh stacks nut
right so what's neck
not everyone needs a computer to crack a
code those are Yale references a neck
washcloth is New Haven street slang for
an ascot the annual Yale Ascot parade is
held in September and the tricky hole in
the skull and on subterranean golf
course is the forth only part mm hole in
Connecticut
ergo neck washcloth parade tricky hole
means September 4th why would a North
Korean official bother using preppy Yale
references as code we hate them enough
as it is because this particular North
Korean official went to
in fact he was my freshman year roommate
oh look at the time I got to go to
Pilates should turn a light on in here
[Music]